DAN BELCHER: Hey, everyone.
I'm Dan Belcher.
And I'm a product manager on
the Google Cloud Platform team.
At Google, we
spend a lot of time
thinking about how we can
make operations easier,
whether you're running
at Google's scale
or you're a new startup
looking to launch
your first application.
Last month, we announced
the beta release
of Google Cloud
Monitoring, which
is our effort to make
monitoring easier in the cloud.
In this session, we'll
give you a quick overview
of cloud monitoring
and its capabilities.
Google Cloud Monitoring
gives you insight
to keep your application fast
and available for end users.
The Cloud Monitoring console
gives you an at-a-glance view
into the overall health of
your application, including
your App Engine modules,
groups of resources,
such as Compute Engine VMs
or Cloud SQL instances,
endpoint checks,
which measure uptime
of your internet-facing
resources, active incidents
or alerts, KPIs, or
recent changes and events
within your application.
With no configuration,
Cloud Monitoring
provides you with rich
dashboards and charts
that you can use to
identify bottlenecks
or issues with key metrics.
You can also configure
alerts so that you're
notified when issues occur.
The system supports a number
of different communication
methods, including email,
PagerDuty, SMS, HipChat,
Campfire, and more.
Cloud Monitoring also
includes rich support
for popular open
source packages,
such as Cassandra,
MySQL, Nginx, and others.
For instance, you can use the
monitoring plugin for Nginx
to gain access to a
variety of Nginx metrics.
Finally, you can tailor
the monitoring experience
to your own needs.
With a few clicks, you can
create custom dashboards
that include metrics
from different components
of your system.
And you can access
advanced charting tools
to investigate issues.
Cloud Monitoring is available
to all Google Cloud Platform
users in beta.
You can access Cloud Monitoring
from any of your projects
by clicking on the Monitoring
link in the left-hand menu
and then clicking
Dashboards and Alerts.
Cloud Monitoring is
an important part
of how we're making
operations easy at Google.
You can learn more about Cloud
Monitoring today by signing up
for the beta or accessing the
monitoring documentation from
cloud.google.com/monitoring.